[Musique]
Hélène buzetti Michel seoger vers un
express bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
il faut parfois et souvent vous allez me
dire qui arrive des drames avant qu'on
décide de serrer la vis de façon
législative Airbnb en est un exemple je
vous fais entendre madame plante ce
matin sur place et dans le vieux
Montréal et la ministre qui expliquait
un peu plus tard qu'elle veut obliger
des plateformes comme Airbnb à inscrire
sur l'annonce sur la publicité du d'un
logement le numéro de certificat de
sorte que il y aura une assurance que
tout ça est fait dans l'ordre et dans un
bâtiment inspecter si possible on écoute
il y a Airbnb ça lave les mains et puis
si je vous fais je vous parle d'eux
c'est parce qu'on a communiqué avec eux
parce qu'on veut qu'il fasse partie de
la solution pourquoi je vous dis ça
c'est parce que
Airbnb à la responsabilité en fait
devrait exiger de tous ceux et celles
qui veulent être affiché leur logement
de mettre leur numéro de certification
les intentions monsieur waouh ça va être
l'obligation pour toute plateformes
d'afficher le numéro
d'enregistrement sur tous types
d'annonces alors le numéro
d'enregistrement sera autorisé par la
corporation de l'industrie touristique
du Québec et mon mandataire
ça ça se retrouve Véronique dans un
projet de loi la ministre nous dit
j'étais déjà en train de l'écrire disons
qu'on va accélérer le tempo un peu là
pas encore été déposé est-ce qu'un
projet de loi comme ça aurait pu éviter
ce qui s'est passé dans les derniers
jours c'est difficile à dire mais ce
serait un cadre réglement réglementaire
supplémentaire parce qu'à Québec et à
Montréal en fait les deux paliers de
gouvernement jugent que Airbnb ajoute
agit en ce moment en toute impunité
c'est à dire que la plateforme exige pas
nécessairement le numéro de
certification puis après ça on vérifie
pas non plus le numéro ce qui fait en
sorte que c'est un peu le Far West puis
tout le monde peut afficher comme ça et
dans les cas d'illégalité ben la
plateforme pose pas de question
finalement c'est vrai que dans certains
cas où il y a des locataires qui louent
les logements et je vais laisser quand
même le bénéfice du doute à certains
propriétaires parce que c'est vrai qu'il
y a des propriétaires qui n'habitent pas
sur place qui ont un immeuble à logement
le loup selon les règles et puis un
moment donné qu'effectivement il y a un
des locataires qui s'amusent à faire du
Airbnb des fois de temps en temps la fin
de semaine ou à la semaine de relâche
etc donc c'est sûr que ça va être très
difficile de mettre toutes les règles
qu'il faudra pour que ce soit
suffisamment encadré peut-être que
l'ultime solution ce serait d'imposer
des amandes qui vont être tellement
imposantes que ça va ça vaudra plus la
peine de louer le logement parce que
c'est très payant encore de Louis son
logement serait Airbnb tout à fait vous
avez raison de le souligner il savait
pas dire que c'est tout ça avait été
fait dans les règles
ça veut pas dire que le feu n'aurait pas
éclaté etc mais ça veut dire que il y
aurait pas eu de locataires Airbnb parce
qu'on n'a pas le droit d'enlever
Montréal à court terme dans cette dans
ce quadrilatère là et on peut supposer
que si tout est fait dans les règles
Michel siog
ça ça veut dire aussi que par exemple la
conformité d'un bâtiment est suivi de
plus près
oui parce que on entendait le grand-père
d'une des victimes tout à l'heure
dans la chambre est-ce qu'il y avait des
détecteurs de fumée pas sûr etc alors ça
ça veut dire des inspecteurs ça veut
dire des inspections ça veut dire
beaucoup d'inspection vous irez voir
combien de logement à Montréal sur un
Airbnb il y en a pas mal puis d'autres
plateformes en plus alors ça il faut
vraiment revoir ça donner probablement
somme municipalité plutôt gouvernement
du Québec qui sont plus proches mais
leur donner les moyens d'agir aussi
parce qu'à un moment donné c'est bien
beau diront on vous donne la
responsabilité sur pas d'argent qui suit
ça va être un gros problème et c'est un
peu ce que dit la mer est plante Hélène
en disant nous on veut bien mais
c'est bien beau une réglementation mais
il faut les prendre sur le fait il faut
aller cogner ou pas ce n'est dans
l'environnement ouvert et dans
l'environnement de ces plateformes là et
c'est assez difficile à tous les Juifs
aussi tout encadré oui oui pierre en
même temps ça me fait un peu rire qu'on
soit encore à l'époque de dire il faut
avoir une plainte un inspecteur aller
voir sur les lieux alors que on parle
d'une économie numérique en tout ça est
rendu possible grâce au plateforme
numériser etc pourquoi ne mettons-nous
pas les le pouvoir des données au
service de de cette cause
c'est à dire de faire respecter les
règles comment se fait-il par exemple
que on n'a pas on instaure pas par
exemple une obligation à Revenu Québec
pour tout citoyen qui fait sa
déclaration de revenus de déclarer le
nombre de portes qu'il possède le nombre
de logements avec l'occupant principal
de ce logement pourquoi on fait pas des
croisements de données avec les comptes
de taxes de la ville de Devil et puis
comme ça on pourrait détecter les
logements qui n'ont pas d'occupant
principal ou document permanent et là
comme ça on pourrait tout de suite
détecter les logements qu'on devrait
vérifier voir lesquels on leur
enregistrement etc on a ce pouvoir
informatique il suffit de créer les
architectures qui se parlent et pour
trouver plus facilement les délinquants
alors que là on
combat des plateformes numériques avec
des poignées d'inspecteur qui doit se
présenter sur les lieux on dirait qu'on
est encore au 19e siècle alors que la
nouvelle ses nouvelles industries sont
au 21e l'âge de pierre et je reviens à
la charge Michel Véronique et Hélène sur
cette oblique quand on fait un commerce
l'obligation de rendre les lieux encore
plus sécuritaires j'allais dire que
quand c'est chez nous mais je vous ai
casser chez nous bien sûr on a une
responsabilité puis le prix à payer peut
être énorme on peut perdre ses enfants
sa famille s'il y a pas de détecteur
mais quand on fait un commerce en plus
de s'assurer que parce qu'il va avoir un
roulement des gens puis des parties puis
la sécurité c'est ça Véronique on n'est
pas armes égales on dirait avec où est
rendu le commerce
c'est clair qu'il y a une responsabilité
de tout cela dedans une responsabilité
du propriétaire effectivement et moi je
remarque dans les vieux quartiers c'est
ici au Parlement on est tout cœur du
Québec qu'on vient d'immeubles il y a où
on avait des petits appartements des 1/2
des 2 et demi plus finalement les
propriétaires ont décidé de faire des
trois et demi des Catherine million
enlevé des murs tout ça ça force sorte
où on contracte ils ont rapetissé les
appartements puis en faisant toutes ces
modifications là qui souvent sont quand
même permise par la ville parce que ça
prend un papier pour être en mesure de
le faire est-ce que la ville vient
vraiment vérifier sur place il y a une
fenêtre dans le dans la pièce et tout ça
il y a tellement
peut-être un manque d'inspection
justement j'en reviens encore au Vieux
Québec parce que comme je vous dis on
est témoin tous les jours ici là je n'ai
jamais vu ou senti d'inspection du
gouvernement dans la rue du Vieux Québec
je ne l'ai jamais sentie et combien de
personnes on a vu se promener comme ça
avec leurs valises pas en direction des
hôtels en direction justement des
immeubles à logement je convaincu que
c'est la même chose dans le vieux
Montréal c'est comme si tout le monde
est un peu de témoin de ça mais tout le
monde a les mains liés finalement et
tout le monde a une responsabilité j'ai
la deuxième pourtant quand un
propriétaire veut faire des rénovations
à Montréal je vous ai Stacy tatillon le
chemin à parcourir pour avoir une
autorisation pour telle poignet telle
couleur et tout Michel
Caroline St-Hilaire
Hélène buzetti est-ce que ça vous
inspirait elle est numéro 2 de la
Francophonie maintenant c'est un poste
qui semble difficile
oui en fait on parle beaucoup de cette
nomination est-ce une nomination
partisane politique pour remercier
Madame St-Hilaire de cette sacrifiée en
se présentant candidate dans Sherbrooke
voilà mordu la poussière pour la 4
évidemment là que il y a une nationale
ici politique quoi que Madame
Saint-Hilaire a une belle feuille de
route a été député à Ottawa mais reste
de Longueuil
je pense pas qu'elle a Rougé sa feuille
de route mais effectivement me
semble-t-il que la vraie histoire se
trouve dans le fait que elle sera la
troisième administratrice générale sous
madame
kiwabo pardon et de il semble y avoir un
problème là de
d'arrimage entre la direction générale
et la présidence les deux premiers sont
partis qui était aussi des Canadiens
sont partis la première madame Cano est
parti en disant qu'elle voyait des
problèmes de dans la gestion madame
mouchikiwabo le deuxième est parti on
sait pas trop pourquoi on le sait que
lorsque cette nouvelle direction est
arrivée c'était un peu pour faire le
ménage à la suite de Michael Jean on se
rappelle aussi une Canadienne est-ce que
c'est simplement le fait que on fait des
réformes on fait du ménage et donc ça
dérange des gens et c'est pour ça que
tout le monde se sent bousculé ou est-ce
que la nouvelle gestionnaire a une façon
de travailler qui n'est peut-être pas
optimale il y a quand même des questions
qui se posent parce que visiblement ça
brasse là et est-ce que ça fonctionne
l'organisme Michel Véronique Michel
ça n'a pas le retentissement puis le
rayonnement qu'on pensait que ça aurait
pour être bien fait des sommets
fonctionnent encore mais ça a pris
beaucoup de temps le dernier sommet je
comprends qu'il y avait pandémie
là-dedans mais c'était très compliqué de
donner tout le monde Tunisie un pays qui
est pas vraiment démocratique
il y a vraiment encore beaucoup de
problèmes et
toute la différence entre le Nord et le
Sud de ce réflexe très fort à la
Francophonie c'est clair puis en plus on
n'a pas réglé la situation de pays qui
sont pas vraiment des pays francophones
qui veulent devenir membres associés
parce que ça fait un club de plus les
fréquenter c'est vraiment l'organisation
qui a des problèmes oui Véronique
conclusion là
et bien Caroline Saint-Hilaire
effectivement elle est là pour revenir
un peu redorer l'image en fait de cette
organisation là aux yeux de Québec en
tout cas parce qu'ils se disent on a une
administratrice parce que à la base
c'est ça c'est quelqu'un qui a gouverné
à la quatrième plus grande ville du
Québec elle a pas été écorchée à la
commission Charbonneau on s'en rappelle
la ville le parti précédent avait été
coché mais pas son administration à elle
puis en plus non seulement selon Québec
elle a ses qualités là d'administratrice
mais en plus c'est une personnalité
publique si qui se présente bien qui a
des bonnes relations publiques avec les
autres qui est capable d'échanger qui
était capable d'avoir une opinion donc
on se dit que l'image de Caroline
Saint-Hilaire en même temps va venir
redorer celle de la Francophonie de
cette organisation là on verra ça très
bien très très bien il me reste peu de
temps j'ai lu un long papier dans le
Star en fin de semaine sur Hélène ça
vous intéresser tout le monde ça va vous
intéresser sur cette ce pacte de
non-agression libéraux et le NPD puis là
je lisais ça ça c'est long puis ils
expliquent comment ça fonctionne ça on
arrive à la conclusion Hélène que dans
le fond ça peut fonctionner jusqu'en
2025 ça ferme
c'est le Paris que j'ai pris bien
franchement Patrice là je pense que ça
va ouais ok
on a le temps d'oublier mon pari mais je
pense qu'il y a toutes les raisons que
ça dure longtemps parce qu'on le voit
dans les sondages le NPD n'en tire pas
vraiment profit ses intentions de votre
diminue pas non plus mais il y a pas eu
d'effets pour le npda pourquoi risquer
de retourner prématurément aux urnes et
de perdre ce pouvoir qui est quand même
très important que détient diagnostic
alors il y a quelque chose d'un peu
presque kamikaze je dirais dans la dans
la posture de Monsieur sing c'est à dire
que il le sait que on le lui reprochera
peut-être à la prochaine élection
d'avoir été peut-être trop complaisant
envers monsieur Trudeau et les libéraux
mais contrepartie lui il se dit au moins
je vais chercher des gains et après moi
le déluge donc il y a quelque chose de
sa posture c'est bien mais évidemment il
y a un coup à ça moi je pense par
exemple au programme dentaire qu'on a
mis en place de manière extrêmement
précipitée pour satisfaire l'impatience
du NPD mais qui donne droit au lieu des
gens on le voit à certains abus le chef
le chèque de 150 dollars est distribué
sans vraiment de vérification sans que
ça corresponde vraiment à ce que les
parents payent est-ce qu'on va se
retrouver dans deux trois cinq ans par
un rapport du véritable qui va nous dire
qu'il y a eu des habits encore là c'est
pas nécessairement optimal d'un point de
vue de gestion des données publiques
Michel c'est un mot là-dessus monsieur
sing c'est comme si ce disait comme on
prendra jamais le pouvoir au moins
jusqu'à 2025 je peux faire avancer mes
politiques et les faire se réaliser puis
après moi comme dit Hélène vous
arrangerez le NPD
mais c'est aussi plus à court terme que
ça
en se disant le il le sait à chaque fois
que les conservateurs menacent de gagner
une élection il y a une partie des
électeurs qui s'en vont libérer la façon
de lire tenir il y a pas de recette
magique mais une des façons de retenir
c'est leur dire sans moi il y aurait pas
eu de plan-dentaire sans moi il y aurait
pas ici sans moi il y aurait pas eu ça
j'ai fait ça de moi c'est pas vrai que
j'ai juste fait poser des questions à la
Chambre et c'est ça le pari que Monsieur
sing prend on verra si ça fonctionne ça
a pas fonctionné dans l'élection
partielle dans banlieue de Toronto il y
a quelques mois mais quand même
c'est de dire je crois juste la
conscience du Parlement j'ai un
programme que je peux faire appliquer
avec
Véronique qui vous restreintes désolé
est-ce que les
conditions c'est-à-dire à ce que les
parties comme la FPD on les moyens
surtout les moyens de se retrouver avec
peut-être le même résultat ou un moins
bons résultats que la dernière fois il y
a ça aussi qui pèse dans la balance donc
c'est un mariage de raison d'habitude
les mariages de raison ça dure pas
longtemps mais parfois les circonstances
font en sorte que t'as pas le choix
Hélène moi je suis pas tout à fait dans
votre équipe je pense ça va être avant
25 mais peut-être je me trompe mais
peut-être vous avez raison aussi c'est
ça qui est beau c'est la beauté de la
discussion merci beaucoup l'année
prochaine salut bonne fin de semaine
bonne fin de semaine bonne soirée waouh